hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game
uh between alexander alejan and uh a
gentleman named davashish from the
1931. uh it's not from a tournament it's
actually from an exhibition game uh let
me just check one more time is it
actually 1931 uh
yeah it's 1931 it was played in
banyaluca and i've seen this game
many times especially since uh i've only
started uh
learning about chess and you know how
how chess
works uh and it's actually an extremely
uh
short game uh 11 moves in total and it's
one of the
one of the nicer miniatures i've ever
seen and ever since i
saw this game i was trying to emulate it
i i tried playing
the exact same moves in tournaments but
my opponent never act never played what
uh vashik played in this game
uh but uh you know the world's a big
place your opponent might play something
like this and you might be able to pull
this off so it
it doesn't hurt to to know this game uh
it was played in 1931 like i said
and although uh alikhin was a bit older
than he is in the in
the in the photo here most of the photos
you have are either from a very young
alien or from a
very old alien so i decided to use the
younger one uh
instead and he's facing the hoodie guy
uh hence uh
the hoodie uh we are we all have to
honor the hoodie guys so i do hope you
guys are wearing the hoodie as well
and now uh without further ado let's
check out this beauty as uh
you you know even though i never
successfully employed it in over the
board
chess in real life you you guys might be
able to do it so here uh alejan opens
with e4 and the hoodie guy replies with
e6 uh sorry about that
uh not the hoodie guy and i do believe
uh that the correct uh pronunciation of
the hoodie guy in this game is vashich
although it could be like anything but
it was played in banya luka so i i do
think
it's a vasich so e6 vashti goes for the
french defense we have d4
d5 and now knight to c3 so sorry knight
to c3 so just a
a regular french defense and bishop to
b4 we have the winner
variation and now bishop to d3 that is
what was played in the game today you
will most certainly see
and you we go into the main line but uh
in those days in 1931 alien played
bishop to d3
uh we have bishop captures on c3 uh now
uh usually you don't want to do this but
we're not gonna dwell too long this is
not an opening video
uh the the previous video lasted over 30
minutes so i'm gonna
make this one shorter but it kind of is
an opening video
in a way that uh will show you how not
to play with black
uh but okay uh bishop captures on c3 uh
giving up your dark square bishop very
early on in the game
b captures on c3 and now uh now you
could continue
in a lot of ways for example you could
capture on e4 and develop the knight
with tempo attack the bishop white has
to retreat then you go knight bd7
castle and so on however here black
played
h6 and remember this is only move five
and
uh h6 is uh well it's a terrible waste
of time sometimes
uh you know i remember in uh you know in
old chess books uh
uh you know some grandmasters who would
be annotating games and they would say
uh wow this move that's a complete waste
of time and even though some of those uh
wastes of time have been refuted by
modern engines and neural networks
uh this move here uh definitely is a
waste of time
and here while you could continue with e
captures on the e5 or queen g4
sorry or queen g4 or something like that
uh here alejan goes for the
absolutely uh well beautiful bishop to
a3 and it cuts off
uh the black king from castling for
example knight f6 and castles is
impossible as the
light square bishop uh white's dark
square bishop cuts off uh
the king's path so here you have to
prepare c5 you can't play it just yet
because the bishop just captures so here
knight to d7 is played preparing c5
and now uh again you could just uh play
something like characters captures and
queen g4 go
after this and it's a really tough
position to play for black however
aliakin played
something that makes this entire uh
miniature possible queen to e2
and now he says okay i'm preparing e
captures on d5 and you're not going to
be able to recapture
because well your king is still on e8 so
here
black decided to play d captures on e4
with bishop captures and now
knight to g2 f6 attacking the bishop uh
we have bishop back to d3 alien of
course doesn't want to trade his light
square bishop it's an excellent piece
and now uh what black should play is
just play c5
and you've uh blocked this uh bishop's
diagonal you're gonna castle and you're
gonna
be very happy about this uh or you're
gonna see something like d
captures on c5 and now queen to c7 if
we want to continue the line knight f3
castles and black is perfectly fine
uh you have to see that c6 doesn't
really do anything because you can just
capture it and the white is not allowed
to capture the rook because of queen
captures on c3 check
and black just wins there's no good move
here for uh for white whatever you do
let's say you block it
black always captures the uh the rook
after the queen blocks captures captures
and then for example you recapture the
bishop and you are up a whole night
so we're going to return here just to
show you that black is
uh perfectly fine here he plays c5 the
game continues however
uh black played b6 and now uh well we
reached the position from the
from the thumbnail and you know nothing
good happens here for black
so uh uh feel free to pause the video
and
win the game for white in great style if
i might add
while i give you a couple of seconds
uh so uh for those of you who are able
to do it congratulations on
once again looking for a brilliant queen
sacrifice
and for those who just want to enjoy the
show it's queen
captors on e6 uh and here you might as
well
resign however the game did continue for
one more move and it doesn't matter what
you play here if you block
the chick with the queen then then just
queen captures his checkmate
and if you don't after queen captures an
e6 you actually accept the queen
sacrifice
then the bishop pair uh you know is more
than fully operational bishop to g6
is checkmate with a beautiful double
bishop checkmate all of these squares
are covered
and that's just it and this is in fact
how the game ended and
i mean wha what a fantastic game so it's
only 11 moves uh definitely a miniature
so we're just gonna uh
go through it one more time very quickly
so uh just a normal french defense
knight c3 and bishop to b4 and you might
want to try like i said i know everyone
goes uh you know just uh e5 or
you know something uh like a3 you could
you could start with
pretty much anything you could either
capture uh but bishop to d3
the you know the continuation that was
played before
you could try it maybe as a surprise in
blitz games maybe you know something
like that
uh and uh you know don't expect your
opponent to play something like h6 but
you never know
you might also be able to pull off a
miniature like this
but of course never expecting chess that
you will actually
pull off a miniature that you know
exactly by heart
but it's important that you know the the
motive behind the position so
if you have a dark square bishop slicing
all the way here and you have this
uh possibility of the light square
bishop landing on g6 so
you might you might look for ideas like
queen capture sun e6 you never know
b6 queen captures and that's just it so
uh
might happen in your own games it might
not but it never never hurts to
to know this stuff uh so yeah uh that's
uh that's the entire game i do hope you
guys enjoyed it a bit of a shorter video
as we had a really long one yesterday
uh i would like to thank uh patrick zone
uh trevor henry
chris picard uh emmanuel ceron and uh
henry thomps
uh henry thon for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the morphe saga checking up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day
and create many many miniatures see you
soon